تثير الفزعه وتلحق اضرارا وخسائر جسيمه
محرمه دوليا وجميع الدول تنكر اقتنائها
منها الخانق ومنها السامه ومنها ما يسبب
الامراض او الحروق او العاهات الدائمه
انها الاسلحه القذره التعرض لها لا يسبب
الموت فحسب بل يؤدي الى معاناه طويله ثم
الموت او اله من قد تستمر مدى الحياه
القنبله القذره احد اشهر انواع تلك
الاسلحه فهي قنبله لا تنشطر نوويا بل تنشر
مواد مشعه قد يصل مداها في الغلاف الجوي ل
1500 كيلومتر القنابل القذره بسيطه
التكوين لكنها خبيثه في تاثيرها على المدى
البعيد ومن ابرز عناصرها المدمره السيزيوم
المشعه الذي يلوث مناطق باكملها
بالاشعاعات
يصبح غير صالحه للعيش لعقود من الزمن
واعمال ترميمها وتنظيفها من الاشعاع قد
تحتاج لمليارات الدولارات اما من ينجو من
الموت وقت انفجارها فيعش ابد الدهر مصابا
بانواع مختلفه من السرطان تقوده الى الموت
في نهايه المطاف
القنبله القديره تعمل بشكل مختلف تماما
ولا يمكنها احداث انفجار نووي وبدلا من
ذلك يستخدم الديناميتا او المتفجرات
الاخرى لنذر الغبار المشع او الدخان او اي
ماده اخرى من اجل احداث تلوث الاشعاعي
ومن الاسلحه الاشعاعيه الى الاسلحه
البيولوجيه قنابل وقذائف تنشر الجدري
والطاعون والجمره الخبيثه وغيرها من
الفيروسات القاتله
الجمره الخبيثه احد اخبث انواع الاسلحه
البيولوجيه فلا يتم اكتشاف الاصابه الا
بعد حدوثها وتؤدي الى الوفاه في غضون 24
ساعه الى 72 خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه
استخدم البريطانيون جزيره
غريناردولوسكتلنديه لاجراء تجارب على
الجمره الخبيثه ما جعل المكان غير مناسب
للعيش لمئات السنين لكن الكارثه الكبرى هي
ما وقع في روسيا منذ اكثر من اربعين عاما
في المركز البيولوجي العسكري في سفير
دلوفيس في روسيا وقع اكبر حادث استنشاق
بشري لجراثيم الجمره الخبيثه عام
1979 حيث اطلقت جراثيم الجمره الخبيثه عن
طريق الخطا ما ادى الى حدوث 79 حاله اصابه
توفي منها 68
والى الاسلحه الفسفوريه والقنابل
العنقوديه والنباللم كلها تصنف ضمن
الاسلحه القذره والخبيثه فالقنبله
الفسفوريه لها قدرات تدميريه هائله فهي
تحدث الحرائق الكبيره لدرجه ان الجيش
الامريكي خلال حرب فيتنام استخدمها لحرق
الغطاء النباتي الكثيف في الادغال التي
كان يتحصن فيها المقاتلون ما جعل
الفيتناميين يعانون كثيرا من هول هذه
القنابل الفتاكه والمحرم
قنابل النابلم الحارقه لا تقل ضررا
فالنبال يسبب حروقا شديده للاشخاص لدرجه
انه يدمر الانسجه العضليه ويصل الى العظام
الاسلحه القذره وان كانت كلفتها رخيصه
مقارنه بالاسلحه النوويه وغيرها الا ان
اثارها لا تمحى من الاجساد ولا تتلاشى من
وفيها تتجسد جميع معاني العنف واللامسانيه